we have some top photos now to show you
some more action around the world number
three in bujumbura burundi around 200
students slid onto the gate of the
American Embassy during protests against
the president's attempt to run for a
third term the US ambassador delivery
came out spoke to the students and
convinced them to leave peacefully
bujumbura has been in a state of unrest
since April when the president launched
a controversial campaign for a third
term sparking widespread protests
including fatal attacks and a coup
attempt and there it is ordinary Kona
yep all right number two following the
springboards ruling on the Affordable
Care Act yesterday the White House
photographer peter Souza tweeted a
picture of President Obama hugging
deputy chief of staff Christie kanagawa
and Vice President Biden honking White
House chief of staff Denis McDonough in
the Oval Office the 6-3 ruling said that
the Obama administration was within its
rights to ground subsidies to
individuals living in states that had
not set up exchanges under the ACA and
as always whenever I see a picture of
the vice president hugging anyone I want
to know what he's whispering right now
so he's saying something good right now
laughs tune into Saturday Night Live for
that all right number one the world's
number one tennis player Novak Djokovic
gave the crowd at the boodles tennis
event quite a gift yesterday after you
want the Wimbledon warm-up match against
Djokovic in Egypt ease for the audience
twirling is charged over his head is it
technically a strip tease that it's just
the shirt Bonnie what are your
expectations this is limited this is
wimbleton you don't you don't do that on
the grass I should point out though that
those are gluten-free ABS Novak Djokovic
we are that is not a dad bod is not a
dad bod